you mentioned byron left which bruce
aaron is a coach of the buccaneers has
been giving leftwich a ton of credit for
being responsible for putting this
offense together
leftwich calls the plays arians just
supervises everything
left which is the one that smoothed
everything over with brady joining
a bunch of guys he didn't know those
guys getting used to brady brady getting
used to them the offense adjusting but
ultimately getting back to no risk it no
biscuit throw the ball down the field
aryan spoke today about his
disappointment over the fact that byron
left which didn't get a
single interview for any of the seven
head coaching vacancies here's arians
you know i was very very pissed that
byron didn't at least get an interview
this year
for the job that he's done i think i get
way too much credit and so does tom
brady for what
the job that byron has done and uh so
yeah i think hopefully next year
um you know people will see that he took
jameis winston and broke every single
record here
uh scoring and passing and now tom has
broken both
um so it's uh it's done a fantastic job
he's everything supposedly what people
are looking for
although this year was kind of a
defensive cycle
and you never know with the owners uh
how they're gonna go so
um but uh yeah i'm very very proud of
our staff
yeah and hopefully leftwich at least
gets an interview next year if he
continues to do the work that he's done
with tom brady with that offense a guy
who was a first round draft pick in 2000
three as a quarterback had a pretty good
career and has transitioned into
becoming
a pretty good nfl assistant coach
and hopefully for him it's just a matter
of time before he gets his chance i mean
the problem is
there's only 32 of these jobs that's a
problem and there are so many
qualified candidates that's one of the
points that jeffrey lurie the owner of
the eagles made on friday when he was
explaining their process
for hiring a new coach so many
candidates
who are good enough and it's unfortunate
that
that some of the guys who clearly meet
that bar aren't getting more
consideration or in left which is case
sharing
any yeah and you know we hear about er
the enemy he doesn't interview well well
byron leftwich has never had an
interview so we don't know how he
interviews right and
it's eric the enemy well he doesn't call
the police or leftwich calls a place and
look
he did a really good job last year mike
too people forget they said well it's
just tom brady
how about jameis winston last year he
did throw for
over 5 000 yards and over 30 touchdowns
i know he had the interceptions those
were a problem
but look they were third best team in
scoring last year third best team in
scoring this year with byron lefferts
i think into the future he does deserve
consideration for a head coaching job
and
you know todd bowles the same way on the
defensive side he's had his chance
before but with what he's done with that
buck's defense i
think he deserves consideration we heard
him say today
that he had an interview set up with the
lions and that was canceled because they
knew they were going to hire dan
campbell and
you guys have talked a lot mike about
the hiring cycle needs to start after
the super bowl to give these chance
to give these guys who are in the super
bowl more of a chance to get some of
these head coaching jobs because
sometimes that does hold up the hiring
process for these guys who are in the
super bowl
you know and another thing that needs to
happen i spoke with the general manager
about this
last week the coaches like eric b enemy
who
if there is this weird sense of not
interviewing well enough whatever it is
the teams that consider the candidates
all the candidates that don't get the
job regardless of race
they're entitled to know why they didn't
get it
why wasn't it him what feedback can be
incorporated by eric b enemy and
other candidates so they can have a
better shot
the next time around now it's a zero-sum
game there's only so many of these jobs
available there's always going to be a
high level of competition but i think it
will help
all candidates if they have the benefit
of knowing
why it is a candid honest truthful and
blunt
assessment why it wasn't that
guy for that job and i think it won't
make it any worse
for them to try to position themselves
like the enemy and other candidates to
get a job the next time around
but it could help hi i'm mike tarico and
thanks for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports